on va retourner à présent à cette
frontière entre ukraine et pologne au
lendemain d'un bombardement sur une base
militaire ukrainienne qui se trouve
seulement une vingtaine de kilomètres de
la frontière polonaise ah il ya vos rive
on retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial dans la région emmanuel chasse
bonjour emmanuel quelle est la réaction
des polonais à ce bombardement à une
vingtaine de kilomètres seulement de
leurs frontières
écoutez c'est vrai que la pologne étant
un voisin direct cette inquiétude même
avant ce bombardement il ya même des
vous savez des missions de surveillance
aérienne on voit ces cercles dans le
ciel depuis plusieurs jours donc
évidemment inquiétude car bombardements
se situe si proche de la frontière et si
proche également de ces files
interminables que l'on voit du côté
ukrainien de réfugiés qui tentent
toujours de fuir leur pays vous pouvez
le voir derrière moi je suis dans ce
corridor à la frontière exactement à la
frontière qui se trouve à juste 20 m 2
mois et des personnes continuent
d'arriver de jour comme de nuit en
assista à un nouveau mouvement de masse
avec des personnes qui peut-être dans un
premier temps n'avait pas pensé devoir
quitter leur pays des personnes
notamment en situation de handicap des
personnes vulnérables des personnes
âgées et bien sûr toujours encore en
grande majorité des femmes et des
enfants toutes ces personnes sont prises
en charge tant bien que mal j'ai envie
de vous dire par le gouvernement
polonais qui ce qui se trouve tout
simplement débordé par set cet afflux 10
ans continue de personnes il ya un
énorme élan solidarité pour l'instant de
la part des polonais mais aussi de la
part de beaucoup de bénévoles étrangers
beaucoup des ong étrangères qui sont
venus prêter main forte au gouvernement
polonais et aux polonais mais une
inquiétude également comment tenir
comment fournir cet effort humanitaire
sur les prochains sur 20 semaines sur
les prochains mois